yeah this is a movie i wanted to talk
about for a while i've wanted to do this
video for a couple of years now and i
know this is one of those videos that
i'll never
feel ready to do you know i know after i
upload it
i'll think of other things i should have
said in the video but
regardless i'm going to talk about it
now because i so love this movie
[Music]
bram stoker's dracula so bram stoker's
dracula came out in 1992 directed by
francis ford coppola stars gary oldman
keanu reeves winona ryder and this
might very well be gary oldman's best
performance or best role there's
definitely an
argument to be made there i mean granted
picking gary oldman's best performance
among his
catalog of performances is kind of like
picking the best dish
at a three michelin star award-winning
fine dining establishment but man he
crushes it as dracula i'm already
getting ahead of myself in this video so
the plot of bram circus dracula is the
story of dracula dracula lives in his
castle he's just known to be this
eccentric count so keanu reeves
character jonathan harker goes up there
and dracula just kind of keeps him there
because dracula falls in love with his
fiancee played by winona ryder so it's a
love story it's a gothic romance maybe
more apt to review this
in february for valentine's day is great
because it's a good dracula story you
know the movie never
lets you forget that you're dealing with
dracula and i love the effects they do
to remind you that this dude is just
evil he didn't start out as evil and
that's also a thing that the movie does
that i really appreciate it shows
why he turns his back on his religion
his god everything and he just kind of
gives himself
over to evil so instantly it makes you
feel for him but that's what the movie
does well you do
feel for dracula which is really
conflicting on one hand you're like this
guy
definitely is evil that just it
surrounds him when he first talks you
hear these
cries in the background that sound like
the ethereal cries of the spectral realm
between that his shadow's not moving
with him at all his shadow in one scene
touches flowers and the flowers just die
on contact
it could have been easy enough to be
like oh yeah he's dracula and you know
that so now we're just kind of
dealing with a person but the effects
they use to remind you that this is
dracula just it feels otherworldly so
not only do you feel that
evil presence all around him in the
movie masterfully reminds you of that
with the effect he just
has on his surroundings but then at a
point he's kind of a love sick dude and
you're reminded yeah it's his life is a
tragedy
he's the victim of his own choices he's
the victim of his own life
i just think gary oldman and francis
ford coppola together really illustrated
this
person in pain uh this charming prince
vlad and also evil incarnate walking the
earth
and you get all of it or maybe not evil
darkness you know it's darkness that
surrounds him and
it seems too easy to say it's evil you
know it's like oh he's just evil and
that's that or
evil surrounds him darkness i think
that's a better phrase
it makes you feel really conflicted at a
point you just kind of feel bad for him
and among all that
i know mushy nonsense right among all
that mushy nonsense
you're still inundated with vampire lore
werewolf form mist form bat form
scenery just stomps on the ground the
crucifix combusts into flame yeah you
feel bad for that creature now is this
keanu reeves best role
no i think there's an argument to be
made
for on the opposite end of the spectrum
there's an argument to be made that this
is gary oldman's best role
argument to be made that this is keanu
reeves worst role and i don't blame him
i don't blame francis ford coppola
everyone has a boss even coppola francis
ford coppola actually wanted johnny depp
for the role of jonathan harker they
were like no you need
a young up-and-coming cast and johnny
depp's just not famous enough
keanu reeves though he's famous enough
and it's just complete miscast the
terrible accent yeah
that's definitely part of it like i'm a
person where i can't tell it's a bad
accent unless it's a really bad accent
like
everybody in bly manor i i didn't know
they weren't british well most of them
are a couple of cast members i did
recognize from other things i knew they
weren't british but
for the most part i'm like well i guess
you're british so i can't tell unless
it's really bad keanu in this movie is
really bad he does one accent very well
and that's
san dimas but he still has that keanu
tone
but british i know where the bastard
sleeps
i brought him there to corfex yeah
it all worked against keanu in this one
which this is a testament to the fact
that
one miscast doesn't necessarily ruin a
movie i mean the contrast between how
bad the keanu miscast is in this movie
to how great the movie is it's
so deep the lg cx series
oled doesn't have contrast this tape all
that is to say
it doesn't ruin the movie but luckily
he's established keanu reeves so he just
he gets the key on the rolls that fit
him now and it works out i really love
anthony hopkins in this movie too
i mean this was after silence of the
lamb so yeah if you can cast him
in this movie you should and they did
but he's crazy anthony hopkins feels
like he's just strolled on set and just
like
just film him and he makes for a legit
van helsing don't mention
the come on he's exactly the character
you think he would be he's the guy who
actually knows the real world this guy
knows that vampires are real he knows
that the supernatural is not just a
bedtime story and he's kind of cracked
and he's weird and he's amazing and what
i love
is the intensity of this movie this
movie has some intense moments
and it usually revolves around gary
oldman having an emotional response of
some sort
and the soundtrack swell the musical
score in this movie i guess there was a
vinyl soundtrack at one point
i hope they re-released that but man
that gothic swell of emotion with gary
oldman giving
us whatever he's giving us in that
moment whether he's melting down in the
beginning renouncing god and
becoming dracula or my personal favorite
that laugh
it's the laugh he delivers in this movie
is the most sinister
villainous laugh since vincent price and
thriller seriously if 2020 had a laugh
it would be this laugh
[Music]
in camera fade i love it and that's
another thing i love about this movie
this movie
really is a labor of love from francis
ford coppola if you have this movie that
has the featurettes the making of and
you haven't watched them
watch them it's so worth it because you
see
what francis ford coppola wanted to
bring and
how he wanted to do it he's using turn
of the century special effects no i'm
not talking turn of the century i'm
talking
turn of the century he wanted to have
and he wanted to deliver and
succeeded in delivering a movie with
in-camera special effects
he wanted the special effects that
existed in the time this movie took
place which makes me have so much fun
every time i rewatch this movie because
i'm always like
that wasn't done on a computer none of
it's done on a computer it's all
in camera but it all it works for the
tone of this movie like that scene
where they have the crucifix and they
walk vampire lucy back into her coffin
they're running the footage backwards
and so it's just it
looks otherworldly and it's 100 times
more effective than any i don't know
cgi thing they can have for maker
floater
however they would do it here in 2020
one of the most effective is the shadow
on the wall like the first time i saw
this movie back in the 90s
the coolest thing was the fact that his
shadow was moving differently than him
and to know that that's not done on a
computer there's a person you know
behind this wall and there's a light
shining on him and he's dressed like him
and
he's just moving differently just kind
of shows that you don't need
a lot of computers to make a compelling
dracula movie
it may look old to some people but it's
it's old in the way the sistine chapel
is old it's like yeah he could be like
oh it looks old
but that's not the reaction you get when
you watch it you're just in
awe it's like a hymn making the call to
have the special effects in this
time capsule for me is one of the things
that makes this movie
timeless and it's not just that like he
went old school with this one he took
the cast and they all went up to coppola
so you know they're throwing back wine
good on them and he'd be like all right
you're all supposed to be friends in the
movies so
hang out and get to know each other they
did improv games
some of the cast members were like it
seems cheesy when you're doing it but it
it does build rapport ram stoker's
dracula's is a very special movie to me
in terms of my
perception of cinema it's the movie that
made it click with me when people
appreciate a movie just on the artistic
level
and i was always like yeah but is it
good do you like it or do you just like
how it was made
i see how the movie as an art piece in
terms of
production and execution and the call
the conscious
decisions made to make this thing a
certain way i can see
how that can click with people and
that's what they appreciate a movie for
and
sometimes that's all they need to
appreciate a movie but it's not to say
all i
like about this movie is how it was made
i just i appreciate that the in-camera
special effects and the techniques he
used to you know
those old-school film techniques was
like all right let's all hang out
which never really happens when
someone's making a movie anymore but it
turns out i just i love this movie in
terms of gothic romance it's
probably my favorite it's a great
dracula story with a lot of great
dracula vampire lore and it uses a lot
of visuals to illustrate the power and
the darkness of dracula and i just love
that but also gary oldman as dracula
is amazing i love this movie when i
first saw it back and i think it was
1995. i think it came on prime time
television and i saw it i was just
hooked ever since bram stoker's dracula
in my book is awesome tacular
and although i've seen this movie many
times over the decades
one of the more recent watches is when
it clicked with me
what george lucas actually wanted to do
with darth vader it was just the
parallel i saw the parallel between
darth vader and dracula where i feel
like george lucas
wanted to essentially make darth vader
dracula because the parallel is there
you know the war hero
whose wife dies and so he just throws
his religion away
then he becomes a tragic monster he's a
guy who needs a hug that's what i'm
saying do you see him hanging out with
francis ford coppola and they're friends
and
i just feel like i have to wonder
whether or not that conversation came up
this made me appreciate the prequels
more when i saw what he was trying to do
with him and actually there was a
criterion release of this movie
on laserdisc they've said they'd like to
go back and
re-release some of those old laserdisc
releases on modern format but it's all
about getting the rights but
really i mean criterion come on 4k let's
get there
all right that's my love for bram
stoker's dracula all right so bram
stoker's dracula have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you